ville du Sud non loin Daudet ça porte
les stigmates de nouvelles frappes
russes il y a des victimes mais aussi
des miraculés comme ce garçon de 11 ans
qui aura passé 6 heures sous les
décombres ou encore cette femme de 74
ans
ça m'a sauvé j'étais allongé là dans
cette chambre et l'explosion m'a projeté
en dehors du lit dans le couloir je n'ai
plus d'appartements maintenant
j'ai appelé un ami et il m'a dit que
l'immeuble avait été frappé nous sommes
immédiatement venus ici
la capitale les sirènes ont retenti
toute la nuit de mercredi à jeudi des
attaques de drone kamikaze ont touché
toute la région selon son gouverneur les
Russes pilonnent en parallèle l'armée
ukrainienne poursuit sa contre-offensive
dans le Sud notamment dans la région
annexée de Carson où les autorités
d'occupation russe appel Moscou à
évacuer les civils
les villes de la région de Carson sont
cibler quotidiennement par des missiles
il touche des hôtels des marchés des
immeubles résidentiels où il y a
beaucoup de civils nous souhaitons donc
faciliter leur évacuation vers la
Fédération de Russie pour étudier et se
reposer
des frappes ukrainiennes qui auraient
aussi touché un immeuble résidentiel de
la ville russe de Belgorod tout près de
la frontière avec l'Ukraine
il y aura